die Lösung lautet Remigration
millionenfache Remigration Menschen die
angeblich nicht deutsch genug sind
sollen zurück in ihre Herkunftsländer
gebracht werden Björn höcke wünschte
sich z.B schon 2018 in seinem Buch ein
großangelegtes
remigrationsprojekt anders als beim
klassischen rassismus wird da nicht in
erster Linie mit biologischen Merkmalen
wie z.B der Hautfarbe argumentiert beim
kulturellen Rassismus geht's um
Lebensgewohnheiten und Tradition es wird
behauptet dass etwas wie Tradition so
tief in den Leuten drin steckt dass sich
Menschen aus unterschiedlichen Kulturen
nie wirklich aneinander anpassen können
dazu muss man sagen bei dieser Idee wird
komplett ignoriert dass sich Kulturen
schon immer gegenseitig beeinflusst und
geprägt haben